So going about and finding
co-founders is a lot like dating.
You want to press the flesh and
leverage your social network and
find out who your friends know and
who their friends know, but maybe not so
much in a social sense but in a business
sense which businesses do you know?
Who do you respect in
these companies and
who can refer you to
the right kind of people?
And when you meet them it's a lot like a
date, you are evaluating each other for
a potential match and a commitment
that's on par with marriage.
Because when you actually go into
business with somebody as a co-founder,
it is a bonded commitment.
You're spending the majority
of your time with this person,
you are looking in the same
direction as the these people or
this person and
you're all committed to the same thing.